- I'm really excited to
welcome Murray Hiebert
to today's Brown Bag
which will be the last
one at the semester.
We've had a very dynamic session
of Brown Bags this semester
with people from all over
the world Zooming in.
Murray is currently a senior associate
of the Southeast Asia program
at the Center for Strategic
and International Studies,
C.S.I.S. in Washington, D.C.
and he has recently completed a book
about China's involvement
in Southeast Asia,
which we will be hearing about today.
I'm especially excited
to have him here today
because it brings me back
to my first year in
graduate school at Cornell
when I was just beginning my
academic study of Vietnam.
I've been working in Vietnam
for over 20 years now,
but back then in the
Kroch Library at Cornell,
his book "Chasing the Tigers:
A Portrait of the New Vietnam",
which was published in 1996,
built from his firsthand
observations in the early 1990s
when he was based in Hanoi
and writing for the Far
Eastern Economic Review,
which at that time,
those of you who have been studying
Southeast Asia for a long time,
was one of the most important
sources of serious journalism
for all of Southeast Asia
and other parts of Asia as well.
Some of you probably remember
our own recently retired
colleague Nayan Chanda,
who also worked for the Far
Eastern Economic Review.
And like Nayan, Murray Hiebert
was part of an important
cohort of embedded journalists
who were offering on the
ground reporting of Vietnam
during important post-war periods.
And his Vietnam books
are especially important
for the portraits they
offer of the early 1990s
when some of the changes
associated with Vietnam's (mumbles) period
and the post socialist reforms
were beginning to come into effect.
And it was a time when society in Vietnam
was rapidly transforming
economically, politically and socially.
And Murray Hiebert was
one of the few people
who was really on the ground
writing about all those transformations.
It's been more than 20 years
since I first read that
book in Cornell's library
and I'm really eager
to be able to meet
Murray for the first time
and to hear what he has to say
about China's involvement
in Southeast Asia.
So please join me in
welcoming Murray Hiebert
to our Zoom edition Brown Bag series.
His talk today,
like his newly published book,
is entitled "Under Beijing's Shadow:
Southeast Asia's China Challenge."
Murray?
- Great, thanks a lot for
that kind introduction, Eric,
and you've really flashed
me back to the old days.
Those were the days actually
in journalism in Southeast Asia,
or in a lot of parts of Asia,
'cause foreign journalists were,
there was quite a few of them,
and we had quite a few outlets.
On the Far Eastern Economic Review,
I was lucky to be working
for them and they,
yeah, they provided a lot
of the early reporting
that was coming out of
countries like Vietnam
that was going through a transition.
Now of course the media
has really shrunk down
the number of journalists.
The Far Eastern Economic
Review no longer exists.
It died in 2004.
It was owned by Dow Jones
that really didn't feel like
they could carry it anymore
when advertising was getting hammered.
Yeah so this, my new book
is about, like you said,
how Southeast Asia is
responding to China's rise.
So what I'll do is I'll try to give some
maybe in about half our time here,
give an overview of the
key themes of the book.
I'll try to intersperse examples
from different countries,
because one thing that
is quite quite clear
when you start doing
this research and writing
is that Southeast Asian countries
are all responding to
China very differently,
depending on how big they are,
how close they are to
China, their politics,
those kinds of dynamics,
and their history with China
is also very important.
But it's fair to say
that all the countries
really do respond to China,
see China as both a
challenge and an opportunity.
The opportunity is that they think China
is gonna yank 'em up by their bootstraps
and help their economies develop,
which is in fact true.
All the countries have
benefited immensely.
And then the challenge
is a considerable concern
about what it means for their
sovereignty going forward,
especially the countries
on the border of China,
which is Myanmar, Laos and Vietnam.
So I go through, I do
it country by country.
That's not always the most
creative way to do it,
but you try to go themes
and it really doesn't work
because the themes are so different.
The issues you need to
cover in each country
is so different.
But I do look at China's
different tools that it brings.
It brings soft power,
including economic cooperation,
cultural exchanges,
Mandarin language training,
more hard power,
that includes threats
in the South China Sea,
economic pressures on countries
that don't do what China wants,
as well as military sales
and military exchanges.
And sometimes it even gets into
considerably sharper power,
like especially dealing
with its communist neighbor,
biggest communist neighbor immediately
to the south, Vietnam,
with which it has had
considerable disputes for decades,
but really in the recent
years a lot of pressure
on Vietnam's oil and gas exploration.
I'll get into that later.
The economic cooperation, as I mentioned,
has really exploded.
China's two-way trade
with the 10 countries of Southeast Asia
was 60 billion last year,
excuse me, 600 billion last year,
which is double the US trade
figures with the region
and it's up tremendously
since China started opening up
in the late '70s and early '80s.
A lot of the economic benefit
also comes from tourism.
It's hard to get accurate numbers,
but there were an estimated
60 million Chinese tourists
that visited the Southeast
Asian countries last year.
That's obviously gonna be
down tremendously this year
because of COVID.
The numbers will be really small
and it really is hurting
countries that rely on tourism,
like Thailand, for example.
And then the other big way
that countries look to China
is the Belt and Road Initiative.
This is China's big signature
economic development project
that it's looking to build
globally railroads and dams
and highways and bridges
and power stations
and you name it.
They even include free trade agreements
or trade agreements in the Belt and Road.
But China has really had trouble,
it's had real difficulties
getting this thing off the road,
off the ground.
Every situation is really complex.
Even tiny Laos that
agreed to build a railroad
negotiated for five years.
You wouldn't have thought
that they would be able to stand
up to China for five years,
but they were negotiating
over the interest rates
and how much Laos would contribute.
China starts by wanting you
to pay for your whole project yourself
and Laos, that would
have been half their GDP,
and so they really fought back.
China also wants land on
both sides of the railroad
so that they can,
you know, their business
people can make money.
And finally, they did agree,
and the railroad is now cranking along.
It'll be finished,
it was to be finished
at the end of next year,
but it might slip into 2022
because of the slowdown
resulting from COVID.
Thailand, which needs to
build the next railroad
so this thing keeps moving
all the way from Koon Ming to Singapore
has been negotiating since 2014
when China thought with
the coup government,
the Prayut government would be able,
that they would be really
interested in doing this
because they were getting
a lot of isolation,
they were getting some sanctions
and other pressure from the
US and the European Union,
but the Thai's and the Chinese
have had over 30 rounds
of talks and they still haven't agreed.
And there, the negotiations
are over slightly more complicated issues
than they were in Laos.
The Thai's say, "Well, we
don't need your money."
Chinese money is not cheap.
They start usually from the EXIM bank,
the Export-Import Bank or
the China Development Bank
usually start around
four and a half percent.
These are both money-making institutions.
They're not aid organizations,
let's say, like, US EXIM or Japanese EXIM.
So the Thai's said,
"Well we don't need that,
we don't need money.
We can get money on the
international market."
They also said, "We don't
need your engineers."
China likes to send lots of workers.
We don't need your engineers.
We got a lot of engineers of our own,
and we don't necessarily
want your technology.
There's German and there's
Japanese and other technology.
And so they're still
fussing around over this.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
They did finally agree on
building a 2.5 kilometer,
get this, 2.5 kilometers
out of several hundred
kilometers of as a pilot project.
And then in Indonesia,
they also built a railroad,
but it's the high speed train
from Jakarta to Bandung.
It's about 150 kilometers.
There, the thing is also
moving slowly since 2015,
when it was agreed upon,
partially because of the
difficulties that China,
Chinese companies and
their Indonesian partners
have in getting land.
So really absolutely every place.
And then actually there's Myanmar
is also another interesting example.
You would think that after they,
Myanmar, the Aung San Suu Kyi government
was involved in kicking
out the Rohingya in 2017
and early 2018 resulted in a
lot of isolation from the West.
You would think they would
want to move ahead with China,
but it's, China has been
negotiating over the Chukwu Dam,
which is on the Western side
of Myanmar on the Indian Ocean.
China has two pipelines,
an oil and a gas pipeline
leading there already,
but they want to also build a port,
a big port that some people
suggest has dual use,
meaning civilian and military and
Myanmar's held them off.
And finally, they have
renegotiated repeatedly
and scaled it back and
still they have not,
no work has started on it.
And the same is true with the Myanmar,
the China Myanmar economic corridor,
which is to lead from Puning down
to several major cities in Myanmar
and include roads and railroads.
And Xi Jinping, the Chinese leader,
was there two years ago
and really put a lot of
pressure on them to get going.
Nothing happened.
They had elections a few weeks ago,
and Xi just called Xi
again this week and said,
"You got to get cranking."
But Myanmar really
is almost as nationalistic
as the Vietnamese.
And so it is tough
for China to get much going there as well.
We don't know exactly how much
China has invested in the Belt
and Road in Southeast Asia,
but there's a consulting
company in Washington
called RWR Associates
and they estimate the
number at about 200 million
in the five years after 2013.
But having visited the countries
and visited a lot of
projects in the two years,
2018 and '19, that I was writing the book,
I really think that number is pretty high.
Some projects also get bogged down in,
sorry, I'm spending a lot of time on this,
but this is really a
signature Chinese project.
And it's good to know
that despite the coverage
you get in the Chinese media,
that this thing is not
cranking along by any means.
The previous prime minister
of Malaysia, Najib Razak,
signed an agreement to build
these East Coast Rail Link,
but he was defeated in an
election in May of 2018
and his successor Mahathir Mohamad 2.0,
he came back after once running
the country for 20 years
and then leaving for awhile,
he was reelected and he put
a stop to it just because of,
he thought China had overcharged.
He thought that there
was a lot of kickbacks
going to Najib and to Najib's
very distressed state investment company
known as 1Malaysia
Development Berhad or 1MDB.
And eventually China agreed to negotiate
but the trial, Najib is still under trial
for some of the corruption
that was spinoff of this and other,
this project and others,
that China was involved in
or were domestic projects.
And we could go on in that vein,
but I'm gonna get going
here on some other themes.
I should say, just one more thing.
If you push back,
as the Laos proved, as Malaysia proved,
if you push back against
projects, even once they're going,
you can get China to renegotiate.
They have been somewhat reasonable
in showing flexibility and
willingness to compromise.
For some countries,
cooperating too much with China
is very controversial domestically.
Last year in 2019, Joko Widodo or Joko Wi,
as he's known for short,
was running again for
president of Indonesia.
And he has relied a lot on China
for infrastructure projects
beyond the one that I mentioned,
the high speed rail
from Jakarta to Bandung.
And he got a lot of criticisms
from his challengers
for depending too much on China.
And I may, I'll get back to Indonesia.
Indonesia has a unique set
of attitudes toward China
dating back to 1965,
when China has been
accused of being involved
in supporting a coup against Sukarno,
who was then the president.
The other area in which
China is very involved,
and this is probably much more successful,
is in the so-called digital silk road.
So that's the digital economy.
China is very active in
investing in unicorns,
the startups worth over a billion dollars,
E-commerce, various E-payment schemes.
Huawei in Southeast Asia
is very active in 5G.
You may remember that president Trump
has been very much opposed
to Huawei being involved in 5G in the US
and has got many friends and allies
in Europe and Australia and New Zealand
to shun Huawei out of fear that they will,
that their technology'll be used
to spy on the local population.
But these companies like Huawei
are also involved in
artificial intelligence,
facial recognition.
In the Singapore airport,
you have facial recognition.
That's been produced by I think it is way.
But Chinese firms like
Alibaba, Tencent, JD.com,
are also investing billions
in startups, like GoJet,
the motorcycle Uber
kind of thing, company.
It's broader than that
but that's how it sort of started,
Tokopedia, Traveloka and
various China fin tech,
Chinese fin tech companies
are also very active in Indonesia.
About two-thirds of China's investment
in the e-commerce and the digital spaces
in Indonesia and Singapore.
I guess that makes sense.
Indonesia is the biggest country
with 160, 170 million people
and Singapore is by far the wealthiest.
There's only two countries
that are shunning Huawei
and that is, not surprisingly,
Erik, Vietnam, as you probably know,
is not terribly enthusiastic
and has shunned Huawei,
and Singapore for 5G
is giving the biggest contracts
to Ericsson and Nokia,
but it's giving Huawei
some minor roles, yeah.
The ethnic Chinese,
there are, we don't know exactly how many,
but probably about two percent
of Southeast Asia's
population is ethnic Chinese.
Many of them came over the centuries,
including at the end of the Xing dynasty.
They came to Southeast Asia off,
mostly in search of
economic opportunities.
They came to places like Malaysia
to aid the British colonial effort,
help with rubber and palm and tin oil,
tin oil, tin mining operations.
But then they started
to play over the years,
a much greater role in the economy.
So they play quite a big role.
The thing that really stunned me though
was the new migration,
which I don't think Beijing
has anything to do with,
but you're seeing increasing numbers
of Chinese come into Southeast Asia.
The places where you see the most of them
are in in Northern
Myanmar, north of Mandalay,
and Northern Laos,
where they are involved in plantations,
rubber, bananas, watermelons,
green beans, pumpkins,
just an awful lot of agricultural,
industrial agricultural products.
Creating a lot of tensions in the region
because they use a lot
of chemical pesticides
and chemical fertilizer,
which is polluting the rivers and causing,
causing bereft animals to die.
Then they also move into some cities.
And there are quite a few,
obviously there were a lot
in Sihanoukville in Cambodia,
especially until the end of last year,
when China got Hun Sen, the
prime minister of Cambodia,
to agree to end online gaming
and a lot of casino gambling.
But there's also a fair,
quite a large number of ethnic
Chinese moving to Manila.
And then the guys who left Sihanoukville
after the clamp down on gambling,
they moved to Kayin or
Kayin state in Myanmar
and they set up casinos there,
Sihanoukoko being one
of the more famous ones.
So I guess I'm a little bit
concerned that long term
the ethnic population in Northern
Myanmar and Northern Laos
can have a huge cultural
and political impact
in those parts of those two
countries in particular.
The history of China with Southeast Asia
obviously goes back to for millennia.
China once controlled northern Vietnam
as a colonial power
for almost 1,000 years.
But after the communists
took over in 1949,
the communist party
supported communist forces
against most of the governments
that were all establishing themselves
after the end of World War II
when many of them got independence
from their European colonial masters.
And this period
when China was supporting
domestic communists,
it still remains a legacy in
many of these countries today.
So this is what,
what is one of the challenges
for Jokowi and other leaders in Indonesia,
that many people still are convinced
that China was involved in a coup
in which hundreds of thousands of people
in the end got killed.
And there's a lot of fear that China
may still be involved politically.
Jokowi himself, the first
time he ran for power,
he was a mayor of Solo,
a little town in Java.
He was accused of being both a Christian
and an ethnic Chinese
and he's pretty clearly
an Indonesian Javanese
who's a Muslim.
But charging people with being Chinese
is often a weapon you
can use against them.
And that's what happened
to mayor who replaced Jokowi in Jakarta.
He was ethnic Chinese.
His nickname was Ahawk.
He was ethnic Chinese and a Christian,
and he got nailed with allegations
of blasphemy for when he tried
to tell a joke about Muslims
and it did not cover very well at all.
Opinion polls, they're tough to figure out
how popular China is but
the Institute for Southeast
Asian Studies in Singapore
does annual surveys.
And the survey that came out in January,
these are elite polls
where they ask officials and academics
and business people and
journalists and NGO people
to give their views.
And the poll that came out in January
had 79% of Southeast Asians
saying China had the most
economic influence in the region.
About only eight percent
thought that about the United States.
But even more surprising was that 52%
said China was the most politically
and strategically
influential in Southeast Asia
and only 27%, about half,
thought that about the United States.
But if they were forced to
choose between China and the US,
which of course Southeast
Asia doesn't want to do,
but 46% chose China, 54%
chose the United States,
which is pretty close actually.
China has really stepped up
military to military ties
in recent years.
It's sold some arms to some countries,
particularly Thailand.
Since the coup had purchased,
the 2014 coop purchased some tanks,
it ordered some submarines.
Malaysia has had some
coastal patrol vessels
purchased from China.
Myanmar and Cambodia also get
quite a bit of military
hardware from China.
Some countries like Indonesia
occasionally look to buy more,
but really in the end, they haven't.
China is also stepping up
its military exercises.
Still way behind where the US is
in terms of frequency and size.
They also offered to do some training
of Southeast Asian officers
in Chinese military schools,
but it's still way
behind what the US does.
China is really very big in soft power.
It provides just oodles of scholarships.
And I say oodles,
because we it's really
hard to get numbers,
total numbers for Southeast Asia.
But in 2016, there were almost 70,000
Southeast Asians studying in China.
By far the biggest number was the Thai's.
23,000 followed by Indonesians, 15,000.
Vietnam I think was 11 or 12,000,
which is still pretty high.
China has also been very busy
setting up Confucius institutes,
which provide Mandarin language training.
There's about 30 now in the region.
Half of them, 15 are in
Thailand, five in Malaysia,
two in the Philippines, one in Vietnam.
And they're also inviting many more people
from Southeast Asia to come visit.
This includes party officials,
not only from communist countries,
but also from Malaysia and Indonesia.
They invite party officials,
PDIP, which is Jokowi's party.
His party sends officials for training
in terms of how do you do budgets,
how you recruit new
members, that kind of stuff.
It's not Marxist, Leninist training.
President Duterte in the Philippines, his,
what's it, PL, oh boy,
I'm forgetting the name of his
party right now, the acronym,
but his party also sends people to,
party leaders to China.
Lots of journalists,
lots of religious leaders.
They really are,
China since the treatment
of the Uighurs in Xinjiang
has become more high profile globally,
has invited a lot of Muslims,
Muslim leaders, Imams to visit Xinjiang.
And many of them come back
speaking very positively.
It's like a work camp atmosphere
where they can pray five times a day,
they can need Halal food, et cetera.
Some are so positive
that the Chinese ambassador will visit,
as happened in the case of one village
in Java in Indonesia.
And he offered to build
them a new irrigation system
thanks to the Imam's very
positive effusive description
of how the Uighur's are treated.
China, I really worked hard
at trying to figure out
the level of Chinese political influence.
You do see some examples,
but it's not nearly as obvious
as it is in Australia or New Zealand.
In the 2018 elections in Malaysia,
the Chinese ambassador,
he actually went and campaigned
for some of the ruling party officials,
(speaking in foreign language)
and the Malaysia Chinese
Association officials.
They actually did quite
poorly and lost the election.
From about the mid 2016 to mid 2017,
China and Singapore were at,
China was in the middle
of an let's isolate Singapore campaign,
partially because the prime
minister had been critic,
had urged China to follow the rule of law
in response to the UN arbitral tribunal
that the Philippines had brought
to ruling overwhelmingly in
favor of the Philippines.
China went ballistic and started,
Singapore is the biggest investor in China
and really started putting pressure,
China put pressure on businessmen.
If you want to keep operating here,
you will have to get your
government to change policy,
which really, should I say,
really irritated the Singapore government
and they didn't really respond
to the businessmen's lobby, I guess.
China is also very active
in phishing and hacking.
And Vietnam,
despite the fact that it
might be a communist ally,
technically quote, unquote,
is often the brunt of it.
When Vietnam was gonna host the APEC,
the Asia Pacific Economic
Cooperation Forum in 2017,
that was gonna be attended
by both Xi and Trump,
China hacked pretty badly.
They often use phishing techniques
where they get officials
to open their open certain software,
malware that goes into their computers,
and they give a dump of
their negotiating strategy.
The Chinese also regularly look
for Vietnam's strategy
in the South China Sea,
try to figure out what the
party is saying about that.
And then ahead of the
completion of the negotiations
for the regional comprehensive
economic partnership,
which was just signed what
about two or three weeks ago,
the Chinese also hacked into
Vietnam's system quite a bit.
Indonesian officials in
the elections in 2019
charged both the Chinese and Russians
with hacking into their voter lists.
The Chinese hacked into SingHealth
where they downloaded just
reams of documentation
about the health conditions
of various Singaporeans,
including Prime Minister Lee.
Some of that stuff
irritates the Southeast Asians
quite a bit, but they say,
they point out that China
is not the only big power
that's constantly spying on them,
which I won't name that other big power,
you probably know where you're sitting.
And I'll conclude with
some comments on water.
I actually realized I'm going
a lot longer than I thought.
One of the concerns is what's happening
on the Mekong.
China has built 11 dams in the
upper reaches of the Mekong,
and then has helped build
dams along the Mekong
as we come through Laos,
Thailand, Cambodia,
and into Vietnam.
The water from China contributes
about 25 or so percent
of the water in the Mekong.
And the Mekong is about,
in Southeast Asia, in Laos,
Thailand, Myanmar, and Vietnam,
about 60 million people
make their living along
that fishing and farming.
The Mekong is one of
the most fertile fishing
sources in the world
and one of the biggest spawning areas
for fish along the
Mekong is the Tonle Sap,
which is the lake in
the middle of Cambodia
that during rainy season explodes
as a tributary of the Mekong
carries water up into the Tonle Sap
and brings a lot of fish with it.
And then in dry season,
the water flows back down
and moves the fish back into
the Mekong main tributary.
And in Vietnam's Mekong Delta,
the level of water matters
a lot because it is,
the Mekong Delta is the
bread basket of Vietnam.
It is also below sea level.
So if it doesn't get water from the Mekong
and silt all the way from Tibet,
it can slip into the sea.
And so what's happened,
the last two years as
China has opened up it's,
or really started running its 11 dams,
the dam number seven and dam number 11,
those two hold enough water
to fill the Chesapeake Bay,
which is not terribly far
from where you guys or
I am sitting right now.
And this has caused a lot of,
because of water being,
rain being less the last few
years than it had been earlier
has caused a severe drought.
And so we are,
the agricultural crops are being damaged.
The spawning of fish is being hurt
and the Mekong Delta in
Vietnam is being hurt.
So this has become a huge issue.
And the Mekong countries
have started to press China on this.
But so far, China has only said,
first of all, they started
by saying they also faced the drought.
We now know that they didn't in fact,
because a group called "Eyes on the Earth"
took satellite photos early this year,
earlier this year about
six or eight months ago,
and found the massive quantities of water
that I was referring to.
And so they, the ASEAN's started
putting a lot of pressure on China.
China has agreed to start giving them data
on how much water they're holding.
We'll have to see
if the countries of Laos,
Thailand, Cambodia, and Vietnam
can exert more pressure
so that China will be more accommodating.
I don't know
if I should,
Erik, should I talk a little
bit about the South China Sea,
or do you think most people here
know about the South China Sea
and we can leave it for
question and answer?
'Cause I realize we have
about 20 minutes left.
- I'd say that if you
just mention it briefly
and then wrap it to a close,
then we'll have time.
And we can linger a
little bit beyond the hour
if you have time, but that's up to you.
Some people will leave right at the hour,
but I'm happy stick around too.
- Okay.
So I'll try to go over the
South China Sea very quickly.
I think that is something that
is covered more in the news
and the US government talks about it.
But the South China Sea,
and this is maybe, you asked me Erik
if I was gonna use a map,
maybe it would have been
useful to have a map of this,
but the South China Sea
has a big U-shaped line,
a dotted line in it, nine dotted line,
which is China's claims to about
80% of the South China Sea.
It claims the fish,
the seafood and the
hydrocarbons in that area,
which is also where Vietnam,
Philippines, and Malaysia
and to some extent, Indonesia,
which actually isn't a claimant,
the claimant countries
disputing with China
are Vietnam, Malaysia,
Philippines, and Brunei.
But part of the nine dash line
runs through Northern Natuna,
which is in the far
Northwestern part of Indonesia.
China's interest in the South China Sea
is relatively recent.
In 2009, based on the UN
conventional law of sea
that was a deadline for
countries to put in their claims.
The main Southeast Asian
countries put in their claims.
China was really irritated
at how much of their claims
overlapped with those of China.
In 2012, China took Scarborough
Shoal from the Philippines
in a pretty dramatic move.
The Philippines brought the case
that I referred to earlier in 2013.
In 2016, the arbitral
tribunal ruled against China.
2016 or 2015, boy, both
dates stick in my head now,
but ruled against China
and China went ballistic,
ignored the ruling totally.
It had earlier,
as soon as the Philippines
brought the case,
started building artificial islands
in the South China Sea,
built up seven islands
by dredging sand and grinding up coral,
which is pretty bad,
because coral is a natural
habitat for seafood.
Four of the islands now have
military landing strips,
so military planes and radar
and missile installations
have been installed.
It is now possible for China
to fly from these bases
to any capital in Southeast Asia.
Two years ago,
China really did ramp
up its pressure again
and tried to press Vietnam and
Malaysia and the Philippines
to abandon some of their
efforts to look for oil and gas.
They started harassing Chinese,
big Chinese coast guard vessels
and maritime militia vessels,
began harassing exploration activities,
and really made it clear,
I think, to Southeast Asia,
their Southeast Asian competitors,
that you really should
stop trying to develop
these hydrocarbons off your coasts
with foreign companies like Shell
and Rosneft and Repsol,
Rosneft being Russian,
Repsol being Spanish.
And either do it with
us or do it by yourself.
None of them can do it by themselves.
So it's really created problems,
especially for Vietnam
and the Philippines,
in terms of wanting to
develop gas resources,
making it possible for
them to fire more hydro,
fire more power
using gas rather than dirty
coal burning technology
that they have all gotten from China.
And in the case of Malaysia,
which is the second largest
exporter of oil and gas,
it is a major source
of government revenue,
about a quarter of the government's
revenue comes from this.
And so one doesn't quite know
how this is all gonna be resolved
but there is a lot of tension
between these countries.
The US regularly sales through there
with so-called freedom
of navigation exercises,
which is intended to tell the Chinese
we don't accept your claims.
Sometimes other countries
have joined the US.
Earlier this year,
both Australia and Japan went along
for a short sale through
by American vessels.
This is the one area though
where the US has been relatively quiet.
But under Trump and beginning in August,
secretary of state Pompeo
began very sharply
criticizing the Chinese.
It was part of a whole anti-China campaign
that you might know deals with Taiwan,
it deals with Hong Kong,
it deals with the Uighur's in Xinjiang
It deals with Huawei.
It puts tariffs on various
forms of Chinese trade
because the US is frustrated
at Chinese stealing
intellectual property rights
and forcing US companies
to do technology transfer
and those kinds of things.
So the water,
both the Mekong and the South China Sea
are two areas where it is
quite possible for accidents
and that could lead into to more conflict.
It is the one area in
which China has a bit,
has a quite a black eye,
in especially the maritime
Southeast Asian countries.
So I'm gonna stop there, Erik,
and let you turn to questions.
Sorry, that went a little
longer than I intended to.
- No, Murray, no need to apologize.
There's a lot to talk about
and you gave a really
comprehensive coverage
of so many issues that
with China's investment
and interactions with Southeast Asia.
So let's open it up to questions.
At this point, anyone who has a question,
if you can use in the
participants tab of Zoom,
there is a function to raise your hand.
That's the easiest way to do it.
And if you can't find that,
just send a message to the
chat and I'll note your name.
We already have two hands up.
We'll start with Jon
Miceler, I believe it is.
And after that, will be Greg Miller.
- [Jon] Thanks very much.
Can you all hear me?
- [Erik] Yes, we can.
- [Jon] Excellent presentation.
Thank you for your time today.
I have a quick question
related to the Belt Road Initiative,
particularly in Southeast Asia.
Do you feel that the
conditions could be created
to make the Belt Road
an enabling condition for sustainability?
Building linear infrastructure, railroads,
roads, high tension wires, you name it,
I mean, all of that comes
with an ecological cost,
but there's a lot of science out there
on how to do that stuff more sustainably.
And I'm just wondering, in your opinion,
do you think there is room
for dialogue with China
to talk about how to
do that in a green way
that actually makes it a win-win situation
for all parties involved?
Or is it really just about
getting it done the cheapest
way to make money for China
and hope for the best
for the other countries?
I mean, do you have any opinion on that?
'Cause I'd like to think that there was
some hope and optimism for the former.
- I think there's hope.
It'll take some time.
You may recall that at
the end of last year,
Xi Jinping hosted a conference
with main recipients of the Belt and Road
in Beijing, I think it was in November.
And he did in his speech acknowledge
that China needed to be
more green in its projects
and less corrupt in its projects,
which I think that was a good start.
And then you might've seen,
I'm trying to remember what
the name of the group was.
There was a European group this week,
I read this in The
Financial Times I think,
did a report making exactly
suggestions like you just did
suggesting that there
should be various ways
to do a lot of these
things in a greener way.
I think what it would require
is countries in the region
also saying we just have
to have greener projects.
The dams that China built,
not only in China, but also several
in Laos and in Cambodia just really are
ecologically very devastating and harmful.
But I think you also have the
benefit of China back home
facing a lot of pressure from environment,
just the population getting tired
of having dirty hair, dirty water,
and wanting more
environmentally sound projects.
And it's interesting that
China now is only exporting
really its worst coal fired plants
to neighboring countries.
They no longer can get away
with doing this at home.
So I think if some of the tensions
were brought down a little bit
that maybe the US and China
could get back on the same page on,
sort of on the same page under
the Paris Climate Agreement,
I think there would be ways to press China
at the highest international levels,
but then also working with countries.
Laos, for example,
they're now trying to build
one more dam on the Mekong.
And I don't know where they
get off on these things.
These things cost two billion dollars.
They have to repay this.
And I didn't even go into the story
where the electricity
distribution company, Laos,
in September had to turn over,
because of its massive
debt to the Chinese,
had to allow China Southern Power
to take over their power grid,
which is just unbelievable.
And I can't believe that
the international community,
the IMF offered other solutions,
but in the end they just did this
they went with the Chinese.
But I can't believe
that Thailand and Vietnam, among others,
wouldn't have just said,
no, we're not doing this.
We'll figure out ways to bail you out.
But then they want to
build another dam on the,
which the Thai's are already saying,
that's the other thing,
you can get neighboring
countries to put pressure on.
So the Thai's after a dam burst
in Southern Laos two years ago,
unfortunately it wasn't
built by the Chinese,
it was built by the South Koreans.
We needed that lever,
but we didn't get it.
The Thai population is saying,
we no longer want hydropower electricity.
Laos has lots of land, lots of mountains,
lots of wind, lots of sun.
Solar is going down,
the cost of solar is going down,
the cost of wind's going down.
Why don't we just introduce that stuff?
And we will buy your power.
And I think if we put pressure
on countries like Laos
and put pressure on the
Chinese internationally
and in the region,
I think you could get quite a
bit of traction to move ahead.
But it would need a lot of persistence
and coordination, I think, yeah.
Good question.
- Thank you, Murray.
I'm gonna turn it over to Gregory Miller,
who has the next question.
- Thank you.
Back in 2017, after the APEC meeting,
Compass in Jakarta ran a front page story,
"Trump versus Xi, Xi Wins".
And from what you've said,
it sounds like that
hasn't changed very much
nor did the Trump
administration seem to care.
Should the US care,
whether we should or shouldn't,
what advice would you give
to the Biden administration
to enhance US influence in Southeast Asia?
- Yeah.
Well you know,
it's a little hard to make recommendations
when you know that
Biden's first priorities
have to be to get control of COVID
and get this economy going again, right,
for so many that are just locked out
thanks to COVID and the
shutdown that related from it.
Yeah, Southeast Asia
really does want the US
to play a more active role.
And when the US,
when Congress passed
the so-called Build Act
about what two or three
years ago, $60 billion,
and then set up this thing called,
they turned the old OPEC
into something called the
Development Finance Corp,
which obviously doesn't
have a lot of money,
it's around 60 billion,
but it's at least a start.
And they're able to do joint ventures
with other countries like
the Japanese or us, even say.
They're also able to do joint ventures
with private companies.
So that might be a possible
way to get involved.
They were really bothered
when the US pulled out of the,
when Trump pulled out of the
Transpacific Partnership.
It's not like that was gonna be
the mother of all platforms to trade on,
but it showed the US was involved
and it provided to Vietnam and Malaysia,
at least some alternatives
to just depending so heavily
on China.
They were very disappointed.
Trump only showed up at one
East Asia Summit meeting.
This is something that
follows immediately after
the ASEAN, the November
ASEAN meeting of leaders.
They do have the East Asia Summit.
Trump showed up once
actually only in Manila.
He gave a speech
and left before the
meeting actually started.
So they remember this stuff.
For Southeast Asians,
you know you show you're
interested by showing up
and the Trump guys, they didn't
show up this year, again,
but it was after the election,
but they sent to the ASEAN Summit
and to the East Asia Summit,
they sent O'Brien,
the head of the National Security Council,
an unconfirmed member of the Trump team,
which is not the highest level.
The year before they sent him,
and what's his name?
Ross, the Secretary of Commerce,
who also isn't the most dynamic secretary
in Trump's cabinet.
So they really,
the Trump team has really
not shown Southeast Asia,
except for the Pentagon,
the Pentagon under Mattis initially,
but continuing has showed up.
It did a lot of exercises,
it did a lot of training,
it kept going with the exercises
that have been going on for decades
and tried to be helpful
to countries like Vietnam,
Malaysia, Indonesia, Philippines,
that have been wanting to,
that really don't have the wherewithal
to see what China's doing
in the South China Sea.
So beginning under
the last few years of
the Obama administration,
the military start providing them
with more maritime domain awareness,
radar, small boats, 25, 30 foot
vessels that they could use
to try to figure out what
the Chinese were up to.
So I think they need to get
more involved economically.
And if they could get involved
in some infrastructure,
that would be good.
And they are.
They've just bid on,
the US companies through
this vehicle, the DFC,
have been bidding on
some projects in Myanmar
on renewable energy.
But they're gonna have to be more active.
And the one thing that the
Southeast Asians don't want
is an all out war, hot war,
but even a cold war between
China and Southeast Asia,
because they provide so much input
to the global supply chain, right?
So Apple, Apple iPhones,
or a lot of the computers
are assembled in China
using technology from
all over Southeast Asia.
So they would not like to see that either.
But yeah, get involved.
And I think Biden's people,
the people he's putting in the White House
and in the state department,
assuming they get confirmed,
are people that are more engagers
than they the guys who were under Trump.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, Murray.
We have one more question
from Daniel Yonto,
sorry about that.
Before we turn to that,
I should note that it is one o'clock.
Those of you who needed to leave at one,
you're free to do so,
but we will keep the conversation going
for another 10, 15 minutes.
I have time for that and
I hope you do as well.
Murray, do you have time to
stay for an extra 15 minutes?
- Yes.
- [Erik] Okay, great.
Go ahead, Daniel.
- Hi Murray.
I really do appreciate the
country by country analysis.
I thought it was really fascinating.
However, you've been
briefly mentioning ASEAN
and I'm curious to what
extent ASEAN countries
sort of as a collective unit
have been able to influence
China in the region?
- Yeah, that is another whole topic
I should maybe have gone into.
So one thing that has
really hurt ASEAN's ability
to stand up to China
is that you need to have
unanimity within the grouping
before you can issue
communiques, for example.
So beginning in 2012,
you might recall that there was a,
that was the year that China
had taken Scarborough Shoal
from the Philippines.
ASEAN tried to issue a statement
and Cambodia was hosting ASEAN that year,
and Cambodia by far is the
country closest to China.
And they had Chinese officials
in some of the visiting rooms
close to where the meeting was happening.
And Hor Namhong, who was
then the foreign minister,
probably one of Ben's
favorite friends, Hor Namhong,
no I'm kidding,
but he would constantly
go check with the Chinese
and in the end, they couldn't
come up with a resolution.
And that really has
hurt the ASEAN's a lot.
Almost every year, there's
an effort at bringing some
just joint statement to
criticize China for its behavior
and they can't do it
because of China's ability to split off
always Cambodia
and quite often Laos
and quite often Myanmar.
Now the thing that's gonna be interesting
is what's gonna happen in the Mekong.
This thing has really been
heating up for most of 2020.
And Vietnam tried to,
I understand from Vietnamese diplomats
that they tried to bring,
raise this issue in ASEAN
thinking that maybe they
would get more support
from countries like Cambodia,
Laos, and even Thailand,
that doesn't care much
about the South China Sea,
'cause it isn't a disputing country.
But it really didn't work.
But it's really interesting.
There is something called,
let's see if I can recreate it now,
I don't use this word every,
this acronym every day,
but there is a UN convention
on non navigable uses of
rivers or something like that,
I don't know exactly what it's called,
but there are 18 countries in Asia,
not only Southeast Asia,
that for whom the source
of their river begins
in China.
And if countries that are losing water
because of China's taking it,
keeping it, storing it,
would all, gang up
maybe is the right word,
maybe if they'd all cooperate
and put pressure on China,
not only a couple of little
countries in Southeast Asia,
but also Central Asia, South Asia,
you might be able to get China
to recognize, yeah if China says,
"If it begins when our country,
we have rights of first use.
That's your problem if
you're further down."
I think China,
if it wants to be a global player
is going to probably have to learn
how to share its toys in the sandbox.
And I think that that,
the Mekong does open up
a whole new opportunity
for getting countries like Cambodia,
if Cambodian farmers,
so China gives Cambodia and
Laos all this aid, right?
But if the cost to their farmers
in rice and fish
is far more than what they
get from China in aid,
are they gonna want to keep doing this?
It doesn't make any sense.
So let's see what happens.
But ASEAN,
because it's based on consensus
has a lot of trouble
putting a lot of pressure on
countries unless they can,
everybody agrees.
- Thank you for that.
- Great.
Our next question is from David Lindsay.
- Yes, am I un-muted?
- [Erik] Yes.
- Can you?
- Yes.
- Thank you very much for this talk.
It's fascinating.
And I want to ask you about
something I heard from
a scholar on Vietnam
in this same lecture
series a few years ago.
He reported that many Chinese vessels
were sinking Vietnamese fishing boats.
It was 2018 or '19.
And he said that the problem
was that the Vietnamese government,
the higher levels,
were now basically on the
Chinese government payroll,
they had been bought out
and so they were not
raising a fuss about this
and that it was,
there were actually
demonstrations in the streets
by fishermen and their
friends and patriots,
but that the Chinese government
was turning a blind eye.
Could you comment on
whether there's some truth
to this story or not?
- So Vietnamese fishermen,
there are two big groupings of islands
in the South China Sea.
The Northern one is the Paracel's,
which the Chinese took from
the Vietnamese in 1974.
You might remember in 1974,
the US backed South Vietnamese government
was still in power.
And they took it from that government,
the US let 'em do it
'cause they were in the middle
of normalizing relations.
But now it's really too late.
The Chinese have now
controlled it for years.
But a lot of fishermen,
Vietnamese fishermen,
from central and Northern Vietnam go there
and they are regularly arrested,
some boats are burned, some are sunk, yes.
They also think boats of the
Filipinos and Indonesians
off their coasts.
Every year, China,
so China puts in force
a moratorium that divides
the South China Sea
and any fishing north
of that line is banned.
It's at the 35th parallel
I think if I recall.
And so they do detain, sink,
more detain and then release
after awhile, fishermen.
But there are some
sinking, that's for sure.
Now domestically, Vietnam has,
Hanoi has a really interesting situation.
In 2018 Vietnam in the
middle of the year, Vietnam,
the national assembly of
Vietnam tried to pass a law
on special economic zones.
That law didn't mention China once.
But the population assumed
that Chinese companies
were gonna get access to land.
And the laws said that
a company that invests
could keep get keep the land for 99 years.
Well, Vietnamese farmers
can only keep their land for 50 years
and then they have to
renegotiate and all that stuff.
So the population went crazy
and really did have huge protests,
both in Hanoi and in the
South and in central Vietnam.
Some of them turned violent.
At a Taiwanese steel mill
in North central Vietnam,
in Tai Ning, in Ting Wa rather, they
attacked the steel mill
that was being built by Chinese workers
for this Taiwanese company.
And two or three or so Chinese
actually died in the process.
The government recognizes
fully that it has,
it's on a very short
leash by the population.
In 19, let me see now, 1997,
the government gave a gypsum
mine in central Vietnam
to the Chinese and even
General Vo Nguyen Giap,
the general who helped win the war
for the Vietnamese communists,
he wrote a letter protesting
giving the Chinese access to
this mine in central Vietnam
in the Highlands, central Highlands.
There is yeah,
and you have academics,
a lot of artists,
lot of people protests
almost anything that the
Vietnamese government does.
Is the government sold out to China?
No.
They are standing up to China a lot.
Sometimes they capitulate,
but the Vietnamese,
I got quite a bit of
access in doing this book
to party officials.
And they said that in 2018,
when China was putting a lot of pressure
on this Spanish oil company called Repsol,
the politburo voted,
I'm trying to remember,
the politburo was 17?
Do you remember, Erik?
Is the politburo, 17 or 19 now?
They've increased the numbers.
I can't remember,
but it's somewhere either 17 or 19.
Two officials voted to abandon
the project with Repsol,
which cost the Vietnamese $500 million.
They owed Repsol around $500 million.
Neither side has said exactly,
but some economists have calculated it
to have cost them that much.
The party chief and the
head of the military
voted to abandon the project.
The rest of the poliburo
voted to stand their ground.
But the two leaders did win in that case
and they abandoned the project.
However, when China repeated
this pressure last year,
the Vietnamese no longer
had a Spanish company,
they had Repsol,
which is a Vladimir
Putin company enterprise,
and they don't stand down easily
for anybody, as you would guess.
And they didn't leave.
And in the end, the Chinese
just sort of wore out and left.
It's a very complicated issue.
But to say that Vietnam,
Vietnam is taking no Belt and Road money.
China has included a very
disastrous project in it
that started actually well
before the Belt and Road.
It's the sky train in Hanoi,
which has been built under
construction for 10 years.
The price keeps going up
and it's never gonna be finished, I guess,
if you're cynical, but,
the Vietnamese are doing the
best they can, I would say,
to stand up to China without going to war,
which they know they can't afford.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
I know it's rambling,
but it's a very complicated
issue in Vietnam.
- No, that's great.
Thank you.
- I'll just add Murray.
I think you were definitely
right on the money
with your answer there.
Also with the recent
politburo change, it was 2016.
I think it's actually the 12th politburo,
but there was a shuffling.
And I think some of the
consolidation of power that occurred
used claims of the previous
prime minister Vo Nguyen,
claiming that he was in
the pocket of the Chinese.
Whether he really was or not,
it's a very complicated thing
to figure out to be honest,
but they certainly
mobilized claims about that
in justification to remove him.
And the current leadership
would certainly portray itself
as strong against China.
We have one last question from,
I think it was Anita Nai, was it?
Anita, did you want me
to read your question that you had posted
or did you want to read
it out loud yourself?
Or are you even still here?
Anita, are you there?
- She said, "Please go ahead", she writes.
- Oh, please go ahead.
I missed it, the chat disappeared.
So I'll read it
and you can see it
yourself as well, Murray,
but I'll read it quickly.
"Chinese FDI into the
US has dropped a lot.
How has the trend been
into Southeast Asia?
One key sector for the FDI is tech",
and there's a list of tech companies,
"And then with tension high
between Australia and China,
has Australia been stepping
up their involvement
with ASEAN affairs?"
Given the time that we have,
you can either answer both
of them quickly or briefly
or one of them.
- Yeah, well this year,
obviously Chinese
investment has been hammered
just because it's so hard to travel.
There's no Chinese are going in and out.
So it will be reduced this year,
but I think generally,
I would say Chinese investment
has really started to take off.
It was slow for a long time,
but it's really started to take off.
The Belt and Road,
maybe it started very high,
it's maybe going down,
but general investment,
including in technology,
as you said and as I noted,
is still really going up.
Australia, it's too early
to really have seen
Australia investment go up
as a result of the Wolf
Warriors going after Australia,
but Australia has been,
over the last oh two or three years,
getting much more active
in Southeast Asia,
cooperating with Japan and others
to play a bigger role in
Southeast Asia, which is,
as a middle power,
Southeast Asia really
appreciates Australia's role.
- Thank you, Murray.
With that, I think we're at
the end of our allotted time.
I want to thank you for such a
fascinating discussion today.
Obviously you've opened so many doorways
to further investigation as well,
and I hope that this topic,
we can keep revisiting during this series.
Also it occurred to me
that it would be very interesting
sometime in the future
to organize a panel discussion,
perhaps with you Nayan Chunda
about the history of the
Far Eastern Economic Review
or to hear about the
time of your journalism,
which was such an important time
in developing on the ground
knowledge about Southeast Asia.
But we'll leave that for another time.
I'll linger until people sign off
and leave the chat open
for a couple more minutes.
But I just wanted to thank you formerly
and I'll press stop on
the recording right now.